Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 93. Ausgabe unserer Gesprächsreihe,
in der wir uns viel mit Wissenschaft beschäftigen und womit sich die Wissenschaft sich so beschäftigt.
Und manchmal beschäftigt sich die Wissenschaft auch mit Dingen, auf die man vielleicht gar nicht sofort gekommen wäre.
So ein Thema haben wir uns heute herausgesucht.
Genauer wollen wir über die Energiewende sprechen unter einem bestimmten Aspekt,
konkret die Energiewende, wie sich denn vor allem im urbanen Raum realisieren lässt.
Ja, und tauchen dort ein und dafür begrüße ich erst mal meine Gesprächspartnerin heute, nämlich Andrea Rumler, schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag, freut mich.
Frau Rumler, Sie sind Professorin dann der Fachhochschule der HWR in Berlin.
Das ist die Hochschule für Wirtschaft und Recht, was ich schon mal eine ganz interessante Kombination finde.
Und sind dort Leiterin des Projekts Mieterstrom plus, das wollen wir heute mal ein bisschen auseinandernehmen
und gucken, was dabei so herausgekommen ist.
Ja, vielleicht mal so zu Ihnen erst mal, wie sind Sie denn da gelandet in dieser speziellen Position?
Man muss dazu sagen, also Ihre Aufgabe sind so Themen wie Online Marketing, Social Media, Compliance Thematiken, internationales Marketing.
Klingt ja auch alles erst mal gar nicht so nach Wissenschaft, wenn man mal so ganz einfach drauf blickt.
Was ist das für eine Kombination, wie hat sich denn das bei Ihnen ergeben?
Dann fange ich mal sozusagen am Beginn meiner Karriere an und erzähl mal ein bisschen,
was ich so im Laufe meines bisherigen Lebens gemacht habe.
Mhm /bejahend/
Ich springe doch mal von hinten, ich bin jetzt schon fast 25 Jahre Marketing Professorin,
ungefähr zehn an der Hochschule für Wirtschaft und Recht, der HWR.
Davor war ich an der HTW auch in in Berlin.
Und ich habe, da ich ja Professorin für Betriebswirtschaft bin, auch mal Betriebswirtschaft studiert vor vielen vielen Jahren in München und in Köln.
Und habe danach mal vorsichtshalber promoviert, weil ich so jung war und dachte,
wer weiß, wofür es im Leben noch mal gut ist.
Professorin wollte ich natürlich nie werden, ist ja klar.
Langweilig.
Langweilig, genau.
So, also die Promotion hatte ich hinter mir und habe mich auf die Suche nach einem Arbeitgeber gemacht
und bin bei Bertelsmann gelandet, der Verlagsgruppe Bertelsmann in München damals.
Also der Hauptsitz in Bertelsmann in Gütersloh, denke ich, weiß der eine oder die andere auch.
Ich war in München und für internationale Verlage zuständig.
In meinem Fall für Fachinformationen.
Da war ich erst Geschäftsführungsassistentin, dann Marketingleiterin.
Wollte aber gerne einen Verlag leiten, das wollten die damals aber nicht einer Frau anvertrauen.
Das ist schon bisschen her, ich hoffe, die Situation ist heute besser im Unternehmen.
Und dann habe ich überlegt, was möchte ich noch so machen im Leben und habe gesagt, einmal in den USA leben.
So, ich habe viele Verwandte da, war viel da und habe gesagt, wann wenn nicht jetzt.
Habe überlegt, was könnte ich anderes berufliches machen und habe einfach mal,
damals gab es das Internet ja noch nicht, da wäre es viel einfacher gewesen, in den Zeitungen geblättert
und ein Angebot eines französischen Möbelhauses gesehen, Möbelherstellers Linie Rosé(?).
Die schrieben, wir suchen Leute, Deutsche für die USA, um uns zu vertreten.
Mit meinem damaligen Freund und späteren Mann haben wir die dann kontaktiert
und ich springe mal, wir sind nach New York gezogen und haben da deren Möbelladen übernommen
und uns auf die Suche nach neuen Möbelhäusern gemacht.
So, das lief auch eine Zeit lang sehr gut, dann sind wir aber wieder nach Deutschland zurück gekommen.
Ich habe Kinder bekommen und dann war die Frage, was mache ich jetzt beruflich mit zwei kleinen Kindern
oder schon nach Kind Nummer eins habe ich überlegt, was ich mache
und habe mich dann auf eine Professur beworben und auf eine andere und relativ schnell hat das auch geklappt.
So und dann sind wir wieder bei dem, was ich seit 25 Jahren mache, nämlich ich unterrichte Marketing im Studiengang Betriebswirtschaft.
Wobei die erste Professur war dann bei der HTW Berlin?
Die erste Professur war, wie gesagt, 15 Jahre lang…
Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft.
Bei der Hochschule für Technik und Wirtschaft, genau.
Und da ich irgendwann dachte, 30 Jahre bei derselben Hochschule oder 35 Jahre halte ich nicht durch,
habe ich dann mal einen mutigen Wechsel von Karlshorst nach Schöneberg unternommen.
Okay.
Da muss ich dann natürlich mal fragen, was macht denn diese Hochschule genau?
Also Wirtschaft und Recht, das andere Technik und Wirtschaft,
da ist halt überall die Wirtschaft drin, da passt natürlich das Marketing wunderbar mit rein.
Wie lange ist denn schon Marketing wirklich auch so ein Forschungsgebiet?
Da muss man USA und Deutschland unterscheiden.
Die Amerikaner sind uns ja bei der ein oder anderen Sache so ein bisschen voraus,
so auch beim Thema Marketing.
Da gibt es den Begriff eigentlich schon, naja vielleicht nicht fast 100 Jahre, aber ich würde mal sagen,
doch relativ schnell nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg wurde das populärer.
Ein paar Sachen, so was wie Produktmanagement sind eher mal Richtung 80 Jahre.
In Deutschland hat das Marketing aber eigentlich erst in den 60er Jahren sozusagen gestartet und abgehoben.
Und hieß damals auch meistens noch nicht Marketing, sondern Vertrieb
und noch in den 80er Jahren gab es eine Reihe großer deutscher Unternehmen, die sagten,
so was böses wie Marketing brauchen wir gar nicht, aber auch die haben heute Marketingabteilungen,
in denen sich die Leute letztlich damit beschäftigen, was die Kunden denn gerne hätten.
Ändert sich jetzt so die Diskussion in der Hinsicht?
Also ich meine, die USA haben ja ein ganz anderes Verhältnis zu Ihrer Wirtschaft so.
Also die Privatwirtschaft, das ist dann auch sehr viel mehr Teil der Kultur, habe ich immer so den Eindruck.
So dieses Wirtschaft durchzuführen, selber wirtschaftlich zu denken, ist in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen normal.
Also so dieses Scheitern auch als Option so, während Deutschland ja immer sehr viel mehr von so einem Sicherheitsdenken vielleicht geleitet ist.
Und sagen wir mal zum Beispiel, universitäre Karrieren eher sozusagen gewürdigt werden und einen gewissen gesellschaftlichen Status haben
als das jetzt vielleicht mit so einem Startup-Denken verknüpft ist.
Das ändert sich sicherlich auch ein bisschen.
Inwiefern hat das dann einen Einfluss auf so einen Forschungsbereich?
Ich würde mal sagen, dadurch, dass die USA in dem Bereich tatsächlich anders ticken,
wenn man mal ganz weit ausholt würde ich sagen, ist das letztlich auch den Kalvinismus geprägt,
dass das Thema wirtschaftlicher Erfolg so wichtig ist in den USA.
Also der American Dream heißt ja nicht, ich werde Beamter, sondern ich werde Multimultimillionär und habe ein Unternehmen.
Während in Deutschland, ich glaube, ich habe neulich eine Untersuchung gesehen, wievielte Hochschulabsolventen Beamter werden wollen,
das hat mich ja als Beamtin fast erschreckt wie viele das sind.
Was war die Zahl, alle?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht.
Startups sind ja inzwischen bei uns auch cool, aber trotzdem ist die Bereitschaft, ins kalte Wasser zu springen
und genau wie Sie gesagt haben, auch mal zu scheitern und dann zu sagen, egal, ich versuche es noch mal,
bei uns nicht so hoch, was eben tatsächlich, denke ich, auch mit dem ausgeprägten Sicherheitsbedürfnis
und der sehr geringen Akzeptanz von neuem in Deutschland zu tun hat.
Von daher hat es Marketing in den USA schon immer viel einfacher gehabt.
Was allerdings dann auch so zu, ich würde es mal, Auswüchse, nennen, von Marketing.
Die sind in den USA sicherlich weitergegangen als bei uns.
Also das, was man aus Verbrauchersicht sagen würde, was letztlich an Betrug oder Übervorteilung Grenzen könnte.
Aber das ist ja nicht die Kernidee des Marketings.
Ja und sicherlich auch nicht der Kern Ihrer Forschung.
Nein, in keiner Weise.
Und Sie werden auch nicht von den Kollegen gedisst oder so, so nach dem Motto, oh da kommt wieder das Marketing, lass mal gehen.
Nein, /lacht/.
Es hat seine Rolle im ganzen System.
Ja.
Wie ist denn Hochschule so aufgestellt?
Also Hochschule für Wirtschaft und Recht ist ja eine Fusion, die vor ein paar Jahren stattgefunden hat,
2009, glaube ich, aus einer rechtsorientierten Hochschule und einer wirtschaftsorientierten Hochschule, die sich zusammengetan haben.
War das nur so, alleine können wir nicht überleben, lass mal gemeinsam gehen
oder war das auch in gewisser Hinsicht eine Erkenntnis, dass diese beiden Themenbereiche gut zusammenpassen?
Also a) würde ich tatsächlich, ich war zu der Zeit noch nicht an der HWR, sondern an der HTW.
Und wenn ich auch noch mal aushole, wir haben in Berlin drei ähnlich große Fachhochschulen,
die inzwischen nicht mehr Fachhochschulen, sondern Hochschulen genannt werden.
Also es gab in dem Zug sozusagen diese Zusammenschlüsse der Hochschulen, die sind neu sortiert worden.
Und die Hochschulen sind ähnlich groß.
Und bei der HWR, der Kern HWR, die Wirtschaft war, die damals FHW, Fachhochschule für Wirtschaft hieß,
bot es sich tatsächlich an, sozusagen noch eine andere Hochschule anzudocken.
Diese beiden Standorte gibt es auch heute noch, die sind in Lichtenberg und Schöneberg und sind ziemlich weit voneinander entfernt.
Und außer der Hochschulleitung und vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, zehn Profs fahren im Jahr relativ wenige Leute hin und her.
Also es ist wie es ist, es sind zwei doch nebeneinander existierende Universen, so etwas.
Auch was das Studium angeht, aber das finde ich nicht schlimm.
Und das Thema Recht ist auch am Standort Schöneberg, wo ich ja bin, vertreten.
Wir haben Studiengänge Wirtschaftsrecht zum Beispiel.
In der betriebswirtschaftlichen Ausbildung ist Recht immer Pflichtbestandteil.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall immer zwei juristische Module, die die Studierenden machen müssen.
Und da ja der klassische Jurastudiengang immer noch mit Staatsexamen endet und nicht auf Bachelor und Master umgestellt ist
und ausschließlich an Universitäten unterrichtet ist, denke ich, bietet sich das an.
Auch die HTW hat im Übrigen einen nicht ganz kleinen Fachbereich von Juristen.
Ich frage natürlich vor allem deshalb, weil gerade jetzt in dem Thema, was wir besprechen,
das Recht jetzt auch nicht eine untergeordnete Rolle spielt, sage ich mal,
es geht ja um die Energiewende in der Stadt.
Energiewende, glaube ich, das ist das Gute, muss man jetzt mittlerweile gar nicht mehr groß argumentieren,
dass die erforderlich ist, das ist jetzt auf dem Weg.
Mit unterschiedlichen Beschleunigungsfaktoren natürlich, und abgesehen von der Energieerzeugung so auf dem großen Level,
also Kraftwerke etc., auf welche Technologien setzen wir da, Ausbau von Windenergie etc. pp.
hat in den letzten Jahren ja auch diese ganze Debatte Energieerzeugung in zunehmendem Maße an Bedeutung gewonnen.
Und da spielt natürlich vor allem die Solarenergie eine Rolle, weil sie auf der einen Seite eben sehr billig geworden ist
und auf der anderen Seite halt auch sehr kleinflächig zum Einsatz kommen kann.
Die kann man überall mal irgendwo so dazwischen schieben und da macht auch das Kleinvieh Mist sozusagen.
Während man das halt so mit einer Windanlage, die stellt man sich halt mal nicht eben in den Hinterhof,
weil die halt auch nicht ausreichend effizient wäre, wenn sie eben nicht sehr groß ist.
Hier spielt also die Größe keine Rolle.
Dieses Thema beschäftigt ja auch die HTW und dieses Projekt, was ich jetzt gerade schon angesprochen hatte, Mieterstrom plus, das Sie leiten,
machen Sie ja auch in Zusammenarbeit mit der HTW und dort konkret in Zusammenarbeit mit Volker Quaschning,
der hier vor vier Jahren auch schon mal zu Gast war, da haben wir auch über die Energiewende an sich gesprochen,
über die Notwendigkeit und all das.
Wie kam es zu diesem Projekt und was ist das Ziel dieser ganzen Aktivität?
Also das Projekt, die Idee zum Projekt kommt von Volker Quaschning, der mich kontaktiert hat vor,
ach weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr, drei Jahren vielleicht und gesagt hat, wollen wir nicht gemeinsam was machen?
Ich beschäftige mich mit den erneuerbaren Engeren.
Es gibt was neues, ein neues Konzept, was Mieterstrom heißt.
Ich wusste damals noch gar nicht, was das ist, da kommen wir ja gleich drauf, was damit gemeint ist.
Wollen wir das nicht näher zusammen untersuchen?
Denn Mieterstromprojekte laufen an und wir stellen fest, die Mieter nehmen die nicht in dem Maße an, wie wir das gedacht haben.
Wir brauchen also jemanden mit der Fachrichtung Marketing an Bord, der versucht zu verstehen,
wie die Mieter denken.
Also Mieterstrom heißt im Prinzip, man erzeugt seinen eigenen Strom als Mieter oder da wo man wohnt.
Auf dem Haus, da wo, also jetzt zu, was ist Mieterstrom, auf Mietshäusern werden Solaranlagen gebaut
und der Solarstrom wird direkt im Haus verbraucht, der darf auch nicht eingespeist oder weitergeleitet werden bislang.
Das ist Mieterstrom.
Und jemand, natürlich stellt nicht jeder einzelne Mieter mal eben seine Solaranlage aufs Dach oder auf den Balkon,
sondern das wird von den Wohnungsbaugesellschaften oder den Besitzern erst mal angestoßen
und dann braucht man eine Betreibergesellschaft, also einen Stromanbieter.
Unser Projektpartner zum Beispiel sind die Berliner Stadtwerke, die eben eine ganze Reihe von Mieterstromprojukten in Berlin schon haben.
Okay. Und das lief also schon eine Weile an und dann hat man gemerkt, weil aber keiner haben?
Keiner würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, aber auf jeden Fall blieb die Beteiligung der Mieter am Mieterstromprojekt unter den Erwartungen.
Sagen wir mal so.
Und bisher ist das ja so, es wird eine Anlage auf meinem Mietshaus gebaut
und dann habe ich vielleicht, ich mache es jetzt mal ganz simpel, einen Zettel im Briefkasten,
möchten Sie auf Mieterstrom wechseln?
So und die meisten Leute sehen den Zettel, legen ihn irgendwo hin und irgendwann landet er im Papierkorb.
Und es war wie gesagt eine zähe Sache, die Mieter dazu zu bringen, sich daran zu beteiligen
und auch die Stadtwerke wollten eben gerne wissen, was können wir machen, um mehr Mieter mit an Bord zu holen
und auch ganz allgemein, wie sehen denn die Mieter überhaupt das Thema Mieterstrom?
Finden die das gut, Solaranlagen auf dem Dach zu haben, ja oder nein.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir jetzt so überlege, ich wäre jetzt ein Mieter in so einem großen Mietshaus, bin ich auch,
aber vielleicht nicht in so einem ganz großen, wie jetzt hier, glaube ich, im Fokus erst mal steht.
Könnte es mir ja erst mal ziemlich egal sein als Mieter, mir gehört ja das Haus nicht,
ich habe ja eh nicht viele zu sagen, ich muss eigentlich nur meine Miete zahlen und damit hat sich das alles erledigt
und wenn der Wasserhahn nicht funktioniert so, dann rufe ich den Vermieter an.
Also ist ja eigentlich eher eine Vermietergeschichte, warum heißt das nicht Vermieterstrom plus?
Gute Frage.
Sind das nicht die ersten Ansprechpartner an der Stelle und können die nicht einfach entscheiden was sie wollen,
inwiefern müssen dann denn die Mieter überhaupt mitgenommen werden?
Naja, wir haben ja in Deutschland schon die rechtliche Situation auch, dass ich als Mieter aussuche, von wem ich meinen Strom beziehe.
Richtig?
Ja.
Also Sie als Mieter, andere Mieter können sagen, ich mache gar nichts, ich bin im Grundversorgungstarif,
ich kümmere mich nicht drum oder ich suche im Internet oder sonst wo einen Anbieter, der preiswerter ist,
ich lege Wert auf Ökostrom und beziehe den und eventuell, wenn ich in einem solchen Projekt wohne,
kann ich auch den direkt auf dem Dach gewonnenen Strom beziehen.
Das muss aber erst mal, dann muss ich eben erst mal einen Vermieter haben, der bereit ist, sich durch das bürokratischen Dickicht,
würde ich es mal nennen, was den Mieterstrom leider noch umgibt.
Ich hoffe mal, dass die neue Regierung jetzt da Schneisen reinschlägt, dass es einfacher ist, auch für die Betreiber, das zu machen.
Aber sobald der Vermieter das anbietet, haben dann die Mieter die Option und die können ja oder nein sagen.
Ja okay, das leuchtet natürlich ein, obwohl man sich irgendwie auch in so einer idealen Welt vorstellen würde,
naja, wenn das Haus selber sowieso schon Strom erzeugt, warum habe ich dann nicht einfach nur weniger Kosten
und ziehe den Rest halt irgendwie aus dem Netz, was die eigene Anlage nicht schafft so,
das wäre ja eigentlich das einfachste da, da müsste ich mich ja gar nicht groß zu äußern,
weil es ja letzten Endes bedeutet, ich wohne da, ich miete da, ich beziehe da meinen Strom aus der Steckdose
und wenn die Steckdose entscheidet, dass ja schon genug vor Ort ist, dann muss ich halt weniger bezahlen,
das wäre ja sozusagen die ideale Welt, aber das ist halt rechtlich nicht so.
Das springt gleich auf eine unserer Empfehlungen, also das was wir, ehrlich gesagt, nicht weiter überraschend rausgefunden haben,
das wäre die optimale Situation, dazu müssten die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen aber erst mal geändert werden,
dass, wenn ich eine Mieterstromanlage habe im Haus, dass das erst mal der Normalfall ist,
dass daher mein Strom kommt und dass ich sozusagen opt out, nennt sich das,
nur wenn ich das nicht möchte, ich dann zu jemand anderem wechsle.
Aber das sozusagen eine Voreinstellung ist, wenn ich mich nicht weiter mit dem Thema beschäftigen will
und das ist ja gleich, wenn man sagt, wie tickt denn die Mieterin und der Mieter, ist das eine wichtige Sache,
die Leute haben viele andere Sachen um die Ohren und Strom ist jetzt nicht das aufregendste und sexyste Produkt, was wir so kennen,
womit ich mich gerne und stundenlang beschäftige, sondern das ist so was, muss ich eben machen,
aber schön finde ich es nicht und ich kann es auch nicht anfassen
und ich sehe auch keinen Unterschied zwischen Ökostrom oder Strom aus einem Atomkraftwerk,
also von daher ist die Bereitschaft der Leute, sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen recht beschränkt.
Und je einfacher man es den Mietern macht, desto besser.
Das ist so der alte Witz, mir ist es egal, wo die anderen ihren Strom her beziehen, meiner kommt aus der Steckdose.
Da ist sicherlich was dran und für manche spielt dann vielleicht auch nur der Preis letzten Endes eine Rolle,
für andere ist es halt auch wichtiger zu wissen, wo es herkommt und das muss man in irgendeiner Form zusammenbringen.
Aber vielleicht ordnen wir doch mal so ein bisschen die rechtliche Situation auch erst mal ein.
Wenn ich jetzt als Mieter vielleicht das mir durchaus wünschen würde, dass so etwas passiert,
weil ich generell am Fortschreiten der Energiewende ein Interesse habe, was ist denn jetzt quasi derzeit so der rechtliche Rahmen,
in dem sich halt auch ein Vermieter letzten Endes oder ein Hauseigentümer letzten Endes bewegt?
Also was sind denn die Probleme, was ist denn der Ausgangspunkt derzeit, an dem man startet?
Wir machen mal die Perspektive, die einzelne Mieterin, der Mieter möchte gerne eine Solaranlage auf dem Dach haben,
wäre der Ansprechpartner die Vermietungsgesellschaft oder vielleicht ja auch Einzelpersonen.
Und die müssten wie gesagt die Antragsbürokratie hinter sich bringen und einen Betreiberpartner finden,
das ist nicht das Problem, also die Partner sind da.
Das Problem, weshalb viele Vermieter, also es gibt zwei Probleme, weshalb die Vermieter und Vermieterinnen eher zögerlich sind,
das ist einmal das schon genannte Bürokratiethema und das zweite, dass es wirtschaftlich sehr grenzwertig ist,
also es ist schwer, die Anlage wirtschaftlich zu betreiben.
Was eben unter anderem auch an dieser schon erwähnten Tatsache liegt,
dass man im Vorhinein so schlecht abschätzen kann, wieviele Mieter sich tatsächlich für den Mieterstrom entscheiden.
Wenn es da eine größere Sicherheit gäbe, denke ich, wäre das Projekt für die Vermieter auch deutlich attraktiver.
Und wenn man jetzt mal auf die Mieterebene geht, kann man natürlich die Leute nur dazu aufrufen zu sagen,
fragt doch mal eure Vermieter.
Es müssen im Übrigen, Sie hatten ja eben gesagt, große Häuser, es müssen gar nicht unbedingt so,
so viele, weiß ich nicht, Wolkenkratzer, Wohnwolkenkratzer gibt es in Berlin ja nun wahrlich nicht.
Nein, aber es gibt natürlich Häuser, wo, was weiß ich, der Dachstuhl auch ausgebaut ist,
von anderen Mietern mit genutzt wird, wo dann einfach auch gar nicht mehr so viel Dachfläche vielleicht da ist oder so.
Ja, das ist richtig und das Haus muss ja auch…
Baulich geeignet sein.
Muss baulich geeignet sein, wir müssen eine Dachausrichtung haben, die mit Solarstrom gut funktioniert.
Also vielleicht eben nicht alles nach Norden, nicht verschattet, was auch immer, also es muss möglich sein.
Das Potenzial ist aber groß in Berlin und auch in Deutschland.
Das weiß man, weil man das schon mal ausgerechnet hat?
Der Projektpartner, die HTW, ist zumindest für Berlin sozusagen in der Endphase daran, dazu einen Überblick sich zu verschaffen.
Und wie gesagt, ich weiß die Zahl jetzt nicht auswendig, aber es ist eine große Zahl der Mietshäuser, die dafür infrage kommt.
Also das ist nicht der Engpass.
Die Engpässe hatte ich schon gesagt.
Und wie gesagt, wenn jetzt die Bürokratie einfacher gemacht würde,
es gibt eine ganze Reihe von wirklich engagierten auch Einzelbesitzerinnen und -besitzern von Häusern,
die sagen, super, möchte ich gerne machen und die dann frustriert durch die Bürokratie aufgeben, das sollte es ja nicht geben.
Ja.
Das war aber nicht der Fokus unseres Projektes, sondern wir haben uns wie gesagt mit den Mietern beschäftigt.
Genau, um einfach mal die eigentliche Frage zu beantworten, warum laufen die uns nicht die Tür ein.
Warum wollen die denn nicht, genau, warum sind die so zögerlich?
Ja, und wie geht man an so was heran?
Also wie geht man an so was heran, man überlegt vorher natürlich erst mal, wie wollen wir die denn befragen?
Und wir hatten uns so überlegt, dass wir erst mal in die Quartiere gehen, wo schon Mieterstrom ist und da mit den Leuten reden,
die einmal Mieterstrom beziehen und dann mit den Leuten reden, die keinen beziehen.
Ich hatte vor meinem geistigen Auge auch persönliche Interviews, als das geplant wurde.
So, geplant wurde das Ganze kurz vor Corona und wir sind mit dem Projekt so richtig zum 01. März 2020 gestartet,
also komplett parallel mit Corona.
Ich habe meine wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin noch beim Bewerbungsgespräch persönlich kennengelernt
und dann haben wir ein Jahr alles in Zoom gemacht.
Und auch unsere Marktforschung ist dann natürlich online gegangen und wir haben eben überlegt,
wir hatten vorher gedacht, dass wir persönliche Interviews machen, weil es ja nicht so leicht ist,
an die Leute zu kommen und vielleicht auch nicht die Mieter in den Projekten unbedingt so technikaffin sind
und wir Bene wirklich einen breiten Querschnitt durch die wohnenden Mieter haben wollten.
Aber wir mussten eben wie gesagt umplanen, das ging auch,
wir haben mit Hilfe von einem großen Trupp engagierter Studierenden Zettel ausgehängt in einer ganzen Reihe von Wohnblocks,
haben jedem was in den Briefkasten geschmissen und gesagt, wir suchen Interviewpartner
und haben eben gedacht, wenn wir das Ganze während der Corona-Lockdown-Zeit machen,
haben die Leute vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr Zeit und haben Lust uns anzurufen.
Wir hatten also einen Anrufbeantworter geschaltet und hatten auch ein Handy,
was die wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin immer mit sich rumgetragen hat,
wenn jemand angerufen hat und dann haben wir Interviewtermine ausgemacht.
Also wir haben Telefon- und Onlineinterviews gemacht.
Online für die Leute, die technikaffig genug waren, das zu machen, aber es gab auch eine ganze Reihe von Leuten,
die gesagt haben, ich möchte das lieber am Telefon machen, im Internet geht das nicht so gut.
So, das war Phase 1.
Wie gesagt, geplant war das eigentlich mal anders, aber ich denke, das war von den Ergebnissen her jetzt auch nicht so furchtbar unterschiedlich.
Und nachdem wir das gemacht haben, wir haben so knapp 200 Leute interviewt auf diesem Weg,
haben wir, das war auch von Anfang an geplant, gesagt, wir schieben noch qualitative Interviews nach.
Also längere Gespräche, so was wie wir gerade machen.
Also wo es nur einen losen Gesprächsleitfaden gibt und wo wir die Leute mal erzählen lassen,
was ihnen so im Kopf rumgeht.
Das haben wir im Frühjahr des letzten Jahres gemacht.
Da war dann Corona-Lockdown, habe ich vergessen, Nummer 3 oder so was.
Also musste das ganze auch wieder komplett elektronisch sein und wir haben das einmal auch über Telefon angeboten,
aber auch über eine Videoplattform, über Zoom und haben 18 Gespräche geführt,
längere Gespräche, so Durchschnittsdauer so anderthalb bis zwei Stunden, haben die aufgezeichnet
und hinterher systematisch ausgewertet.
Das war also unser Erhebungsteil.
Also und vor allem auch eher weniger Gesprächsteilnehmer, also kleines n, aber dafür sehr viel umfangreicher abgeklopft.
Sehr viel umfangreicher und wir wollten ja auch so was wie Bedenken,
verborgene Bedenken, Sachen, die den Leuten nicht gleich so in den Kopf kommen,
sondern die erst, wenn man ein bisschen weiter bohrt, dann rauskommen.
Da kommt man mit so fünf Multiple-Choice-Fragen nicht weit.
Das geht eben wie gesagt mit einer Online-Befragung, selbst wenn man die auch telefonisch parallel macht, geht das nicht.
Die Ergebnisse waren aber jetzt nicht… überraschenderweise gingen die in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Also die haben wir nur noch mal sozusagen zum Crosscheck genommen, um zu sehen,
ob das auch die Ergebnisse, die wir aus der Befragung hatten, tatsächlich dem standhalten der zweiten Befragung.
Und wir habe noch eine ganze Reihe von ausführlicheren Statements gefunden, weil wir wollen ja eigentlich…
Also meine persönliche, also der Part der Marketingleute in dem Projekt sozusagen, meine Ausgangshypothese war,
es ist mehr die Kommunikation mit den Mietern, als dass es tatsächlich Bedenken zum Produkt Mieterstrom sind.
Und das hat die Untersuchung deutlich bestätigt.
Das war schon die erste Antwort auf meine Frage, die ich noch gerade einschieben wollte,
wie geht man denn da jetzt ran, mal jetzt mal von der Wissenschaft her, von der Methodik her,
man weiß, okay, wir werden jetzt nur so und so viele Gelegenheiten überhaupt haben, ein Gespräch zu führen,
dann investieren zwei, drei Stunden und werden noch mal viel mehr Stunden damit verbringen,
die dann auch auszuwerten, da ist es dann natürlich extrem wichtig, dass man auch vorher weiß,
okay, was wollen wir eigentlich genau fragen?
Weil kann ja auch sein, dass man dann am Ende feststellt, okay die Hälfte der Fragen hätten wir uns sparen können
bzw. da kriegen wir jetzt überhaupt gar keine nennenswerte Information raus
oder noch schlimmer, das hätten wir mal fragen sollen, haben wir aber jetzt nicht, jetzt stehen wir schön doof da.
Wie macht man das methodisch?
Gut, ich meine, klar Erfahrung kann hier schon mal eine Menge helfen, aber so vom Ansatz her,
wie entwickelt man so einen Fragenkatalog oder wie entwickelt man einen Dialogansatz, sage ich mal,
um dann auch die Ergebnisse zu bekommen, die man haben möchte?
Also die Antwort auf Ihre eigentliche Frage, wie macht man das methodisch, ist, man macht Pretests,
einen oder mehrere Pretests.
Also man macht Probedurchläufe, das haben wir bei beidem gemacht,
bei den qualitativen Interviews als auch bei den qualitativen.
Und das ist auch ganz wichtig, also dass man das testet und guckt, hakt es irgendwo,
also das haben wir rauf und runter gemacht, bevor wir damit sozusagen wirklich losgezogen sind.
Rauf und runter heißt so wie lange oder wie oft?
Bis man merkt, es sitzt.
Das kommt ja drauf an…
Dreimal, zehnmal, hundertmal?
Wir sind jetzt bei den qualitativen eher mal so was wie zehnmal.
Bei diesen Tiefeninterviews, also den qualitativen Gesprächen macht man keine zehn Probeinterviews,
da macht man vielleicht so was wie zwei bis drei.
Es kommt aber ja wie gesagt auch darauf an, wie gut die Ausgangssachen sind, die man sich überlegt hat.
Es gibt noch eine methodische Antwort, was man macht, also außer dass man sagt, man testet vorher,
wie gut das ist, was ich gemacht habe.
Die zweite Antwort lautet, ich denke mir nicht alles alleine aus, sondern ich gucke,
ob die Sachen, die ich fragen will, schon mal woanders und in anderem Zusammenhang gefragt worden sind.
Ich mach mal ein Beispiel.
Also in unserer qualitativen Untersuchung der Online- und Telefonbefragung, der ersten,
haben wir Skalen zur Messung von Umweltbewusstsein benutzt.
Die haben wir uns nicht selber ausgedacht, sondern die sind von anderen Wissenschaftlern entwickelt worden und auch geprüft worden,
ob die, man muss ja auch gucken, wird überhaupt das gemessen, was wir messen wollen, mit dem was wir da machen.
Also zum Beispiel das Item Umweltbewusstsein und haben wie gesagt solche Skalen eben übernommen
und nicht selbst angefangen, uns was auszudenken.
Was fragt man da so?
Weil Sie jetzt hier mein Umweltbewusstsein mal abklopfen wollen würden, was wären dann so die Fragen, wie man das rauskriegt?
Also auswendig weiß ich die Items nicht, aber solche Sachen…
Pi mal Daumen.
… so was wie Verhalten, recyceln Sie, machen Sie sich Gedanken über die Umwelt, ist Ihnen die Umwelt wichtig?
Grundsätzlich wichtig, wollen Sie aktiv dazu beitragen?
Also da gibt es so eine Batterie, also so eine Liste von Statements, dann misst man eben,
wie sehr die Leute zustimmen, von gar nicht zustimmen bis stimme vollkommne überein.
Und letztlich kann man dann einen Mittelwert daraus machen.
Und wir haben ja Mieterstromkunden und Nichtkunden verglichen.
Wir wollten ja wissen, wo ist der Unterschied und dann wollten wir auch wissen,
was denken denn die Nichtkundinnen und -kunden, und wie können wir die vielleicht rüberholen?
Und zum Beispiel war eins unserer Ergebnisse auch wieder nicht sehr überraschend,
die Leute, die jetzt schon Mieterstrom beziehen, haben ein deutlich höheres Umweltbewusstsein.
Wie gesagt, gemessen mit diesen Skalen, die es in dem Fall vom Bundesumweltministerium mal entwickelt worden, als die Nichtbezieher.
Nicht überraschend, klar, aber auch das ist ja eine Information.
Ja.
Weil das heißt ja dann, okay wir haben zumindest nicht gleich bei der ersten Frage schon eine Situation, mit der wir gar nicht gerechnet haben.
Und so was könnte ja darauf hinweisen, dass man einfach falsch misst so.
Ja, also alles andere wäre jetzt überraschend gewesen.
Und vielleicht sage ich jetzt schon mal ein zweites Ergebnis und das, finde ich, ist eins de sehr erfreulichen Ergebnisse,
die Leute, die bisher nicht Mieterstrom beziehen, sind größtenteils stehen die sehr positiv dem Konzept gegenüber.
Es ist gar nicht so, dass die sagen, das finden wir total doof und wir wollen keine Solarpanels auf dem Dach,
sondern so was wie zwei Drittel bis Dreiviertel davon können sich entweder sehr gut
oder zumindest so ein bisschen vorstellen, auch Mieterstrom zu beziehen.
Es gibt nur eine ganz kleine Gruppe von Leuten, die sagt, das wollen wir nicht.
Also sie haben eigentlich das Tanzkostüm schon an, aber sind noch von niemandem gefragt worden, ob man auch tanzen möchte.
Ja.
Verstehe.
Ich meine, das klingt immer so ein bisschen einfach so, wir haben ein paar Fragen gestellt und dann gibt es so ein paar Antworten
und dann misst man das irgendwie.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man in so einer statistischen Auswertung auch eine ganze Menge Fehler machen kann.
Wie geht man da so ran?
Also Eingabefehler schließe ich jetzt mal aus.
Wir sagen mal, wir haben keine Eingabefehler gemacht.
Na, man kann ja Auswertungsfehler machen.
Man kann ja sozusagen die falschen Schlüsse ziehen oder so.
Auf jeden Fall, man kann ja auch die falschen statistischen Methoden verwenden für etwas.
Ja, wie schließen wir das aus, wie schließt man das grundsätzlich aus?
Mit dem viel-Augen-Prinzip.
Ja, dass viele Leute drauf gucken und man miteinander redet, welche Auswertungen werden gemacht
und dass man bestimmte Sachen testet, dass man guckt, ist das auch signifikant, was wir da rauskommen haben?
Das haben wir natürlich.
Also das, worüber gerade jetzt geredet haben, Mieterstromkunden haben ein höheres Umweltbewusstsein als Nicht-Mieterstromkunden,
das ist ein signifikantes Ergebnis.
Also das haben wir mit den geeigneten statistischen Tests überprüft.
Und nicht einen simplen Mittelwertvergleich gemacht.
Das meine ich.
Und natürlich überhaupt erst mal drauf kommen, dass man so was überhaupt abfragt,
gehört ja im Prinzip auch so ein bisschen zur Systematik.
Ja, das gehört auf jeden Fall auch dazu und um darauf zu kommen liest man …
also das hört sich jetzt fast trivial an, aber man muss sich natürlich in das Thema erst mal einlesen.
Also ich war vorher keine Stromexpertin, ich bin jetzt auch immer noch keine Stromexpertin,
aber ich kenne mich zumindest bei Mieterstrom aus und ich weiß jetzt relativ genau,
wie die Mieterstromkunden und -nichtkunden ticken, was ja auch das Ziel des ganzen Projekts war.
Genau, darum ging es ja, also rausfinden, wie kriegt man die Leute mitgenommen
und ja, das Problem haben ja auch andere politische Maßnahmen, auch jenseits von Energiewendefragen,
wo man sich ja auch manchmal fragt, ja warum machen dann nicht alle mit?
Ich meine, mir würde jetzt mal so aus dem Stand einfallen Mülltrennung und so was, ja.
Muss man ja immer nur den Zustand unserer Mülltonnen anschauen, was wo drin ist,
dann denke ich mir auch immer so, könnte man vielleicht auch mal so eine Befragung machen,
um mal so rauszukriegen, wie macht man eigentlich die Ansprache so, dass es auch funktioniert?
Dass irgendwie nicht das Plastik in der Biotonne und das Bio im, was weiß ich, und was ist eine Mehrwerttonne?
Ja, also ich stehe da ja auch selber manchmal davor und denk mir so, bin ich jetzt eigentlich blöd
oder wird nur falsch mit mir geredet?
Das ist so ein generelles Problem, glaube ich, was durchaus überdacht gehört.
Na gut, also es wurden quantitative, also mit quantitativer Befragung meinen wir sozusagen Dinge,
die sich mehr oder weniger auf so einem Skalenwert dann stimme sehr zu, stimme nicht zu.
Es kommt eine Zahl raus.
Genau, es kommt eine Zahl dabei raus, darum ging es.
Und die qualitativen Sachen sind dann eben so ein bisschen mehr so der Podcast, wo man sagt,
okay jetzt sage doch mal wie du dich fühlst.
Ja, touch and feel, genau.
Genau. Kenne ich.
Okay, das heißt, nachdem man sich das alles zurechtgelegt hat und dann diese Befragung gemacht hat,
also erst kam, wie ist das gelaufen, also man hat mit jedem sowohl das eine als auch das andere gemacht?
Oder man hat erst mal das Quantitative gemacht?
Wir haben erst qualitativ und ein Jahr später qualitativ.
Ja okay.
Und auch wir haben…
Aber auch teilweise mit denselben Leuten oder /unverständlich/ mit denselben Leuten?
Das ist eine interessante Frage, die ich gar nicht beantworten kann, weil das ist nicht auszuschließen.
Wir haben die Leute für die qualitativen Interviews in denselben Wohnanlagen gesucht.
Aber die erste Befragung ist ja zum Teil auch anonym gewesen, wobei wir haben,
um die Leute dazu zu kriegen teilzunehmen, haben wir Zootickets nicht verlost, sondern jeder,
der bis zum Zeitpunkt X teilnahm, hat zwei Eintrittskarten in den Zoo oder Tierpark bekommen,
also von daher hatten wir theoretisch schon die Adressen, aber wir haben die natürlich von den Antworten getrennt
und haben die auch nur für den Versand der Zookarten benutzt.
Also wie gesagt, von daher weiß ich das nicht genau, aber ich weiß ja,
bei den qualitativen Interviews hatten wir einige Leute dabei, also einige Mieterinnen und Mieter,
die sehr für das Thema brennen.
Ich vermute also, dass die in der ersten Befragung auch teilgenommen haben.
Gut, also wenn man jetzt so eine quantitative Auswertung macht, dann kann man ja dann schön die Ergebnisse auch in so ein Ranking einstellen.
Und es gab ja jetzt im Wesentlichen diese zwei Gruppen.
Leute, die da schon mitmachen, Leute, die da noch nicht mitmachen, worin unterscheiden die sich denn?
Was lernt man denn sozusagen daraus?
Ja, was lernt man daraus?
Ich habe schon gesagt, die Mieterstromkunden haben ein höheres Umweltbewusstsein.
Denen ist die Herkunft des Stroms auch deutlich wichtiger als den Nichtkunden.
Den bisherigen Nichtkunden ist das Thema Preis deutlich wichtiger.
Es muss ja auch für manche, viele Leute haben ja auch nicht die Wahl,
entsprechend haben auch die bisherigen Mieterstromkunden, die das schon machen, ein durchschnittlich höheres Haushaltseinkommen
und einen durchschnittlich höheren Bildungsgrad.
Wir hatten vorher vermutet, das war eine unserer Hypothesen, dass das Vorhandensein von Kindern in einem Haushalt
das Thema Mieterstrombezug oder nicht beeinflusst.
Also dass Leute mit Kindern sich von den anderen unterscheiden.
Mehr an die Zukunft denken.
Was rausgekommen ist, nicht immer kommt das raus, was man sich wünscht,
was rausgekommen ist, ist das Gegenteil.
Ich erkläre aber gleich meine Hypothese, weshalb ich denke, dass das so war.
Also rausgekommen ist, dass die Leute bisher keinen Mieterstrom beziehen, deutlich eher Kinder im Haushalt haben als die Leute,
die Mieterstrom beziehen.
Ich vermute, dass das was mit der Einkommenssituation zu tun hat.
Wir haben eben auch ganz klar gesehen, dass die Leute, die Kinder im Haushalt haben,
dass für die das Thema Preis sehr viel wichtiger ist.
Und man muss sich auch die durchschnittlichen Haushaltseinkommen der Leute angucken,
die an der Befragung teilgenommen haben.
Also da waren Haushaltsnettoeinkommen von über 2000 Euro schon, ich glaube, das haben irgendwie nur so 25 Prozent oder so was gehabt.
Also wir waren viel sozusagen im mittleren bis eher mal unterem Einkommenssegment unterwegs.
Klar.
Da sind eben diese Projekte ja auch.
Und noch mal, völlig verständlich, dass für eine Reihe von Leuten der Preis die erste Priorität hat
und wenn man Kinder hat und das Haushaltseinkommen beschränkt ist
und die Ausgabe sowieso hoch, dann sagt man eben, Hauptsache billig und nicht Hauptsache öko.
Ja und vor allem hat man auch irgendwie eine Menge um die Ohren, wenn man Kinder hat,
dann ist man auch nicht so im Informationsbusiness unterwegs.
Auch da möchte man nicht so viele Formulare ausfüllen müssen, sondern möchte es möglichst einfach haben.
Gut, aber ich meine, daraus kann man natürlich lernen, klar, es gibt, sagen wir mal, jetzt so die Avantgarde,
die hat mehr Mittel und ist irgendwie, sagen wir mal, aus generellen Motivationen heraus bereit, da mitzumachen.
Aber wenn man quasi alle mitnehmen will, muss man sich auch letzten Endes über solche Sachen wie den Preis Gedanken machen.
Das heißt, das spielt am Ende eine große Rolle.
Ist auch schon mal eine interessante Information, die man daraus bekommt,
weil wenn man das dann halt vermarkten möchte, muss man dieses Argument auf jeden Fall mit in der Tasche haben.
Wobei man jetzt sagen muss, Mieterstrom ist ja nicht automatisch teurer.
Also es gibt eine gesetzliche Rahmenbedingungen, dass der Mieterstrom 10 Prozent unter dem Grundversorgungstarif liegen muss.
Aber der Grundversorgungstarif für Strom ist ja nicht das billigste, was man am Markt einkaufen kann.
Nicht das billigste, was man erzielen kann.
Das kommt aber jetzt eben wirklich auch auf den jeweiligen Wohnort an, was wie teurer ist.
Ich denke mal, ohne da deutschlandweite Zahlen zu kennen, dass der Mieterstrom sicherlich mit dem Ökostrom standhalten kann vom Preis.
Also dass er da auf jeden Fall nicht drüber ist.
Aber auch da wie gesagt wäre das wünschenswert, wenn der Mieterstrom, da der ja am Ort des Verbrauchs auch erzeugt wird
und damit auch nicht gespeichert und geleitet werden muss, dass der einen Preisvorteil hat.
Ja zumal ja die Kosten eigentlich für diese Stromerzeugung im Falle von Solar eigentlich im Wesentlichen Investitionskosten sind.
Richtig.
Was kostet das, die ganze Technik zu kaufen, was kostet, die ganze Technik zu installieren?
In gewisser Hinsicht auch noch, was kostet es, sie zu betreiben, aber das ist ja, sagen wir mal, würde ich sagen,
eher im zu vernachlässigenden Bereich.
Klar, die Panele sollten vielleicht ab und zu mal gewaschen werden, aber ansonsten, wenn sie nicht kaputt gehen,
dann funktionieren sie halt irgendwie auch 20 Jahre und ja laufen eigentlich die ganze Zeit und liefern ja direkt Strom,
wieviel Geld muss wirklich in die Hand genommen werden.
Weil ich denke, kein Mieter wird jetzt ernsthaft widersprechen, wenn man ankommt und sagt,
ja, also du kannst jetzt deinen Strom für die Hälfte haben, weil wir installieren das jetzt hier auf dem Dach, womit du nichts zu tun hast.
Dann sagt man so, ja guten Tag, hätten Sie es gerne billiger?
Ja schon so. Und dann läut der Hase ja auch.
Ja, wobei es muss ja auch nicht notwendigerweise billiger sein, aber es muss einfach,
also auch Erkenntnis unsere Studie, auch nicht überraschend, der einfache Zugang dazu.
Also dass man sich als Mieter möglichst wenig damit beschäftigen muss.
Wie gesagt, das was ich gesagt habe, eigentlich wünschenswert wäre, dass das ein Automatismus ist.
Ich ziehe neu in eine Wohnung ein, es gibt Mieterstrom auf dem Dach,
den bekomme ich, außer ich entscheide mich dagegen, also diese opt out Option,
die wie gesagt rechtlich im Moment noch nicht geht.
Aber Gesetze kann man ja auch ändern und ich bin mir sicher, dass da auch drüber nachgedacht wird, das zu verändern.
Also das wäre schon mal ein erster großer Schritt.
Und ansonsten, was wir auch aus der Befragung gesehen haben ist,
Mieterstrombezieher wie -nichtbezieher wollen eine transparente Preisgestaltung
und wollen einfache Tarifsysteme.
ich mache mal ein anderes Beispiel, die Handyverträge in der Anfangszeit der Handys waren ja der Albtraum.
Nicht nur in der Anfangszeit.
Ja gut, das hat sich ja schon deutlich gebessert.
Bisschen.
Hat sich deutlich gebessert.
Ich persönlich finde auch die Stromverträge nicht ganz so super überschaubar,
auch wenn das vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher ist, aber auch da wäre es sicherlich möglich,
das einfacher und so, dass es jeder versteht zu gestalten.
Ja, also einen rechtlichen Rahmen dafür zu machen, was sozusagen in Verträgen abgebildet werden muss
bzw. welche komplizierten Rabattmodelle und Tages-Nacht-Verbrauch etc. vielleicht unter Umständen gar nicht statthaft sind
oder nur in eingeschränktem Rahmen.
Das sind auch nicht nur die Gesetzgeber, das sind auch die Anbieter, die das vielleicht noch nicht auf dem Schirm haben.
Ja klar, aber der Gesetzgeber kann ja da an der Stelle durch Regulierung natürlich auch entsprechend vorschreiben, dass es so und so zu sein hat.
Und ich denke mal, was sicherlich auch noch ein Aspekt ist, ist auch die Stabilität.
Ich meine, wir nehmen jetzt hier diesen Podcast auf im Februar 2022 und die letzten Monate waren dadurch geprägt,
dass halt auf dem Strommarkt es richtig losgeht.
Also die Energiepreise sind durch politische Unsicherheit, Situation in der Ukraine, noch ein paar andere Ereignisse,
generell auch durch das Problem dieser Lieferkettendisruption durch die Corona-Krise,
sind einfach die Preise gestiegen, teilweise so extrem, dass diese Billigstromanbieter teilweise in Insolvenz gehen mussten,
die Kunden kriegen natürlich dann immer noch Strom, gehen dann in die Grundversorgung,
was für die aber dann eben unter Umständen eine Preiserhöhung zur Folge hat, weil natürlich die Preise auch angepasst werden,
insbesondere wenn man halt einen neuen Vertrag dann aufnehmen muss, dann steht man erst mal blöd da
und hat halt nicht den Vorteil eines Vertrages, der vor fünf Jahren vielleicht ein bisschen sicherer abgeschlossen wurde.
Naja und so ein Solarpanel auf dem Dach, kann man schon mal sagen, das bleibt relativ stabil.
Richtig.
Das ist ja schon auch ein Versprechen an der Stelle.
Wurde ja auch abgefragt, nehme ich an?
So Preisstabilität.
Ja.
Ja, wobei man auch natürlich der Fairness halber dazu sagen muss,
nicht der gesamte Strombedarf von so einem Mietshaus kann im Laufe des Jahres mit dem Solarstrom vom Dach betrieben werden.
Ich muss auch Strom zukaufen für Monate wie, wir gucken aus dem Fenster, gerade scheint ein bisschen die Sonne,
aber so sehr viel hat sie in den letzten Wochen nicht geschienen.
Für die Zeit, wo die Sonne einfach nicht scheint.
Also es muss Strom dazugekauft werden, der unterliegt tatsächlich den Schwankungen des Strommarktes,
die wir gesagt ja gerade erleben in dieser Zeit.
Aber der Mieterstrom ist deutlich preisstabiler und von daher vermute ich mal, dass jetzt gute Zeiten sind,
um Mieterstromverträge abzuschließen.
Sie hatten ja anfangs erwähnt, dass es hier vor allem jetzt erst mal um den lokalen Verbrauch geht, aber nicht um die Einspeisung.
Aber gerade unter diesem Gesichtspunkt der Stromstabilität, ich meine, Mieter, wann sind die halt nicht da, tagsüber,
dann sind sie irgendwie arbeiten und haben andere Dinge zu tun bzw. man verbraucht vielleicht auch einfach nicht so viel Strom,
weil eigentlich kommt der Stromverbrauch halt nachts, wenn man das Licht einschaltet, wenn man wieder nach Hause kommt etc. pp.
Das heißt, das ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen ein Problem, sprich, so eine Solaranlage funktioniert fürs eigene Haus eigentlich nur in dem Moment,
wo man dann entweder ein großes Speichersystem hat oder zumindest mit Strom, der in dem Moment, wo er erzeugt wird, nicht gebraucht wird,
dass man den dann halt wieder einspeist.
Also inwiefern ist das denn jetzt Teil des Mixes oder wurde das gänzlich ausgeschlossen
oder ist das rechtlich derzeit gar nicht möglich?
Bei Mieterstrom, ich meine, dass Mieterstrom inzwischen …
Also erst war Mieterstrom beschränkt wirklich auf das Haus, auf dem die Anlage ist
und ich meine, man kann inzwischen innerhalb einer Mietanlage umleiten, aber das hilft ja auch nichts,
wenn, wie Sie beschreiben, die Leute weg sind und erst abends den Strom verbrauchen.
Letztlich ist die Frage, wann gibt es die Speichersysteme, die bezahlbar sind und die dann helfen,
diesen sozusagen Entstehungs- und Verwendungsgap zu überbrücken?
Ja oder halt eben auch losgelöst von einem einzelnen Mietobjekt hin zu einem ganzen Block oder Stadtteil oder was auch immer.
An der Stelle vielleicht auch einen zentralen Speicher zu benutzen, würde ja eigentlich ganz sinnvoll sein.
Ja.
So wie es jetzt Parkhäuser gibt, könnte man ja auch mal nicht nur Autos speichern,
sondern irgendwo halt auch einfach mal so eine Stadtteilspeicherstelle vornehmen.
Und wenn halt überall so Solar rumhängt und tagsüber wird das eben nicht verbraucht,
naja dann speichert man es halt da rein und bezieht eben den Strom von 100 Meter um die Ecke, sage ich mal.
Aber das war jetzt hier nicht im Fokus.
Nein, und wie gesagt, noch sind die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen dafür auch nicht da, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall wünschenswert.
Gab es denn auch Leute, die gesagt haben, ja nein Mieterstrom will ich nicht haben, kommt mir nicht ins Haus?
Ja gab es, aber wie gesagt, wir waren überrascht, wie wenig das waren.
Was gibt es da für Argumente, gibt es da welche?
Das Thema Preis hatten wir ja schon.
Und dann gibt es noch eins, das haben wir noch gar nicht diskutiert.
Wir haben ja eben schon gesagt, die Deutschen sind so vorsichtig und sicherheitsbedacht.
Auch bei dem Thema, wir haben, ich meine, bei 9 Prozent der Leute Sicherheitsbedenken gehört.
Also die gute Nachricht ist, 91 Prozent der Befragten hatten keine Sicherheitsbedenken, aber immerhin.
Ja.
Fast 10 Prozent hatten Angst, dass sich das vielleicht mal entzünden könnte oder irgendwas anderes passiert.
Also ich persönlich bin auf die Idee noch nie gekommen, ich wäre jetzt auch bei den 91 Prozent.
Aber die Leute gibt es auch und denen muss ich das ja, …
Also noch mal, wir glauben, wir sind der festen Überzeugung, dass es ein Kommunikationsproblem ist mit dem Mieterstrom.
Also dass man sehr viel mehr Leute mit ins Boot holen könnte, wenn anders kommuniziert würde.
Und das hießt natürlich auch, dass ich die Leute, die solche Sicherheitsbedenken haben, irgendwo abhole.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, gut, wie kann man das Ganze noch schmackhaft machen?
Also ich glaube, dieses reine Stromliefern und bisschen weniger bezahlen, das ist so ein Aspekt.
Ein anderer Aspekt war ja dann auch noch, was kann man quasi dann noch so drum herum bauen,
was für zusätzliche Dienstleistungen wären vielleicht noch sinnvoll?
Ich denke, man muss da auch kreativ sein in dem, was mit Strom sich alles noch so machen lässt.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich so Sachen wie Ladesäulen oder so, die jetzt auch in zunehmendem Maße ja bei Häusern nachgerüstet werden sollen,
insbesondere wenn da Parkgaragen oder Parkplätze zumindest da sind, das wäre ja dann vielleicht auch ganz sinnvoll,
dass wenn jetzt die Waschmaschine nicht läuft, dann kann man ja zumindest den Strom auch mal in die Autos laden,
so denn welche vorhanden sind, ist das auch Teil der Befragung gewesen?
Ja, wir haben abgefragt, ob Zusatzdienstleistungen gewünscht werden, wie eben Elektroladesäulen
oder wie SmartHome-Anwendungen, so was wie ein Strommesser für Haushaltsgeräte und so weiter.
So gute 30 Prozent fanden das interessant.
Welchen Teil davon? Die Ladesäulen oder?
In der Reihenfolge, die Ladesäulen und die SmartHome-Anwendungen.
Wenn ich jetzt das persönlich mal bewerte ist das auch, was zu erwarten war, dass die meisten sagen,
naja brauche ich ja nicht, ich habe kein Elektroauto und die anderen sagen erst mal,
grundsätzlich ist das interessant, aber das ist nicht, ich sage es mal so,
das wird nicht der Gamechanger sein meiner Meinung nach.
Wenn ich mal vielleicht auch eigentlich noch mal auf mein Kerngebiet Marketing zurückkommen kann,
was wir empfehlen, was man machen müsste.
Wir haben da uns Theorien angeguckt von amerikanischen Forschern, vielleicht hat das der ein oder die andere schon mal gehört,
das heißt Nudging, also to nudge, wie kann ich jemanden anstupsen, etwas zu tun.
Also wie schaffe ich es, Verhaltensänderungen, so was wie die Mülltrennung, die wir eben besprochen haben,
wie schaffe ich es, meine Nachbarn dazu zu bringen, dass sie nicht immer alles in die eine Tonne kippen,
sondern sie die 30 Sekunden nehmen und die Sachen mal aufteilen.
Also wie gesagt, da gibt es sehr interessante Theorien zu, die auch schon in der Praxis sehr erfolgreich angewendet worden sind
und ich mache mal ein Beispiel, etwas, was wahrscheinlich fast alle von unserer Zuhörer schon mal gesehen haben,
wenn im Hotel irgendwo ein Schild steht mit, bitte tun Sie dieses Handtuch nicht gleich auf den Boden,
sondern benutzen Sie es so lange es geht und legen Sie es erst auf den Boden, wenn es gewechselt werden soll.
Da sind umfangreiche Forschungen zu gemacht worden, wie sollte man diesen Text auf dem Schild machen?
Und man nutzt dabei etwas, ich will jetzt nicht zu viel Theorie reinbringen, aber das sind die sozialen Normen,
soziale Erwünschtheit, soziale Gruppen, wenn man da reinschreibt, die meisten Benutzer dieses Hotelzimmers verwenden ihr Handtuch fünfmal
und tun es erst irgendwo hin, wenn es anfängt zu stinken, so steht das nicht auf dem Schild.
Aber wenn man sagt, die Mehrzahl der Leute verhält sich umweltbewusst und das richtig gut kommuniziert,
dann nehmen sich die Leute da ein Beispiel dran.
Also wir alle orientieren uns unbewusst, natürlich in unserem Verhalten, manche auch bewusst,
sehr deutlich an dem, was die anderen tun.
Also ich kann, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel in einen Hauseingang reinschreibe,
schon ein Drittel der Bewohner dieses Hauses bezieht Mieterstrom, mehr kann ich in den meisten Häusern nicht dran schreiben,
dann ist das schon mal, wenn ich dran schreiben kann, schon 70 Prozent der Leute in diesem Haus,
ist das natürlich umso besser.
Aber die Leute orientieren sich an dem, was die anderen machen.
So und wenn ich das kommuniziere, das ist ein Zuwachs, schon 30 Prozent mehr als im vorigen Jahr beziehen Mieterstrom,
hilft das den Leuten, dass sie dieses kleine, ich setze mich mal fünf Minuten hin und fülle ein Formular aus, einfacher tun.
Das ist ganz wichtig, das kostet nichts und das hilft.
Oder wie bei der Flugbuchung, nur noch fünf Sitze verfügbar.
Ja, das sind die Darkpatterns.
Ja.
Wir wollen keine Darkpatterns verwenden.
Ich dachte mir auch so, einfach hinschreiben…
Sondern wir wollen natürlich auch nicht, dass da was falsches steht, sondern schreiben was ist.
Und ich mache noch ein Beispiel.
Wäre aber einfach, einfach zu sagen, ja 75 Prozent haben hier schon Mieterstrom, was ist mit dir?
Ja, ja, das wollen wir aber nicht empfehlen.
Nein, weiß Gott nicht.
Was wir auch für sinnvoll halten, dass es in den Häusern angezeigt wird, dass den Leuten visualisiert wird,
dass sie sehen, dass diese Anlage arbeitet.
Also dass es zum Beispiel im Flur ein Panel gibt, wo dann am besten noch schön leuchtend zeigt,
gerade arbeitet die Anlage mit 89 Prozent und im Übrigen werden heute 54 Prozent des Stroms im Haus von der Solaranlage am Dach.
Oder so und so viele Euros mussten nicht bezahlt werden, weil…
Genau. Alles mögliche, was man da drauf schreibt, so dass ist a) eine tägliche kleine Erinnerung
und ich werde positiv verstärkt, ich sehe, wow ich bin Teil davon, das ist super.
Und auch die Gäste aus anderen Wohnungen werden auf die Idee gebracht.
Auch das, es ist alles rund um das Thema sozusagen soziale Normen, Gruppen, Einfluss von anderen.
Ich finde das eh jetzt gerade interessant, weil ich meine Marketing, so wie wir das ja auch eingangs besprochen haben,
insbesondere mit diesem Hintergrund USA, wo es herkommt, hat halt eigentlich immer diesen Nimbus mit,
ich will dir was verkaufen, und hier geht es ja eigentlich gar nicht ums Verkaufen,
sondern hier geht es ja eigentlich darum, ich sage mal, so eine Art soziale Verhaltenssteuerung mit zu befördern.
Nicht die Leute zu was überreden, was sie eigentlich nicht wollen, sondern eben dieses,
hör mal, uns allen geht es irgendwie besser und auch du hast was davon, wenn wir unser Verhalten so koordinieren,
dass wir das und das tun.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen eine unterschwellige Botschaft.
Und ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ob der Begriff Marketing jetzt so glücklich gewählt ist in dem Fall,
weil es halt immer sofort von Markets und damit so Angebot und Nachfrage hat,
auch wenn es natürlich in dem Moment was anderes meint.
Ja, es ist ja eigentlich mehr so eine, keine Ahnung, Informationsbeschickung und -mitnahme,
also vielleicht bedarf es da auch noch mal eines anderen Begriffs oder vielleicht gibt es ja auch einen, keine Ahnung.
Ich finde den an der Stelle, ja der hat ein bisschen Verwechslungspotenzial, sagen wir es mal so.
Aber trotzdem, das ist ja eigentlich das, was hier gemacht wird, dass man sich mehr Gedanken darüber macht,
nicht nur, was wäre die richtige Politik, über die wir uns ja eigentlich am laufenden Meter unterhalten.
Jeder hat immer so einen Beitrag zu leisten mit, ja man sollte ja das machen und warum wird denn das nicht getan und so.
Und die Antwort ist ja oft, ja weil du nicht mitmachst oder wenn du das Angebot bekommen würdest,
dann es halt einfach bleiben lässt oder dich nicht in dem Maße einbringst, wie man es jetzt erhoffen würde.
Und das hat ja auch so ein bisschen was damit zu tun, das steckt ja hier auch mit drin,
überhaupt auch ein Bewusstsein über die Effizienz solcher Maßnahmen zu haben.
Also ja, sie könnten an sich wirken, tun sie aber nicht, weil die Leute machen nicht mit.
Warum machen denn die Leute nicht mit?
Ja, weil das und das.
Also meine Frage ist sozusagen oder meine Aussage, ist diese Untersuchung auch so ein bisschen so ein Plädoyer,
so was genereller auf die Gesellschaft loszulassen, solche Studien oder solche Befragungen,
mehr Teil eines sozialpolitischen Prozesses werden zu lassen?
Ich gehe erst mal einen Schritt zurück und versuche mal, das Wort Marketing, keine Sorge, keine Diskussion, was ist Marketing,
aber jetzt mal zu ersetzen, ganz westlich ist doch die Frage, wie kommuniziere ich mit den Leuten?
Und das hatte ich ja eben schon gesagt, das war unsere Ausgangshypothese, dass wir denken,
und das hat die Untersuchung auch bestätigt, es geht nicht darum, dass die Leute Mieterstrom nicht gut finden,
die meisten Leute auch, die überwältigende Mehrheit der Leute, auch die den nicht beziehen, finden Mieterstrom ein gutes Konzept.
Aber sie beziehen ihn nicht, weil die Gründe haben wir schon genannt, vom Preis bis zur Bequemlichkeit
und aber auch, weil die Kommunikation noch verbesserungsfähig wäre.
Und das ist das, woran wir arbeiten wollten und wir sind auch gerade dabei, ein Folgeprojekt zu beantragen,
wo wir so was überprüfen wollen.
Wir wollen eine Wohnanlage nehmen und sozusagen die Hälfte der Häuser mit unserer Kommunikation ausrüsten, so wie wir die machen würden.
Wir, die Wissenschaftlerinnen, die an dem Projekt arbeiten, und Wissenschaftler,
versus sozusagen die bisherige Kommunikation, um dann mal wirklich zu zeigen,
davon gehen wir auf jeden Fall aus, um wieviel kann man die Beteiligung an den Projekten dann steigern,
wenn man mit den Leuten so kommuniziert, wie die Marketingwissenschaftler, Entschuldigung für das Wort,
wie die Marketingwissenschaftler das empfehlen.
Also so ein AB-Test sozusagen ganz klassisch?
Ja.
So was war noch mal die zweite Frage?
Ja, inwiefern das… also auch wenn es jetzt vielleicht kein tolleres Wort gibt oder das vielleicht auch egal ist,
also ich wollte das jetzt nicht schlecht reden, ich wollte nur sagen, es ist ja in der Wahrnehmung so,
dass es sich hier so um ein marktwirtschaftliches, privatwirtschaftliches Instrument handelt.
Und nicht unbedingt jetzt eine wissenschaftliche Methode.
Es ja aber hier an dieser Stelle ganz konkret ja benutzt wird, um eben politisch etwas zu ändern
oder sagen wir mal, gesellschaftspolitisch etwas zu ändern, Verhaltensänderung zu fördern,
wo man einfach sieht, naja wäre halt für alle besser, wenn man das tun würde, warum tun es denn nicht alle?
Aha, es sind ja gar nicht alle dagegen, sondern es fehlen einfach nur ganz kleine Schubser, diese Nudger sozusagen.
Ja.
Man muss eigentlich nur hier und da was machen und das ist ja dann auch oft weniger energieintensiv, das zu tun,
jetzt mal im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Man könnte also mit relativ kleinen begleitenden Maßnahmen Leute dazu bringen, dass andere Dinge sich überhaupt erst lohnen,
losgetreten werden können, Förderungen auch Sinn machen, besser akzeptiert werden.
Wir haben ja gerade in diesem Energiebereich oft auch diesen Fall, ja okay, wir habe jetzt hier so ein neues Förderprojekt aufgesetzt so,
hat aber keiner bezogen oder auch in der Corona-Pandemie, ja alle Schulen können sich jetzt irgendwie Filteranlagen bestellen,
macht aber dann keiner.
Ja warum denn nicht?
Ja, weil Bürokratie, Aufwand, Zeit, falsch verstanden, keine Ahnung, irgendwas.
Und man weiß dann halt gar nicht, ja warum denn nicht?
Die Politik kommt dann schnell so, ja wollte ja keiner haben, brauchen wir nicht mehr zu machen,
obwohl es vielleicht einfach nur so ein reines Prozessmanagement am Ende ist,
aber keiner dann sich die Zeit nimmt, sich wirklich anzuschauen, ja warum denn eigentlich nicht.
Gut, jetzt werde ich mal sozusagen fast philosophisch und sage, das ist ein Problem,
was die Politik schon lange hat, dass sie eigentlich letztlich gar nicht richtig kommuniziert hat mit den Bürgern.
Es gibt aber auch Leute, das ist ja jetzt nicht neu das Problem und es gibt auch schon Politiker, die das erkannt haben,
aber es ist eben ein längerer Prozess und ja klar, das können natürlich auch nicht die Wissenschaftler alleine lösen,
überhaupt nicht, das erfordert in der Tat eben eine Umgestaltung von Prozessen,
so was wie Bürgerräte zu bestimmten Themen zum Beispiel.
Aber wie gesagt, verlässt jetzt das Mieterstrom-Thema und verlässt auch sozusagen unseren kleinen Beitrag zu dem Thema.
Unser kleiner Beitrag zu dem Thema ist wie gesagt, zu sagen, ändert ein bisschen an der Kommunikation
und wir vermuten ganz stark, dass das deutliche Auswirkungen haben könnte.
Aber eben auch der Aufruf an die Politik, ändert die Rahmenbedingungen und baut gefälligst diese völlig überbordende Bürokratie ab.
Über die wir jetzt noch gar nicht so viel gesprochen haben, inwiefern die eigentlich jetzt das Problem ist.
Ich sage mal, wenn man so ein Haus hat jetzt nur voll motivierte Mieter, die sagen,
ja, Mieterstrom, warum nicht gestern schon, ich bin dabei.
100 Prozent aller Mieter in so einem Haus wollen das haben, der Vermieter sagt, ja, top, spitze, machen wir sofort.
Und dann?
Ich kann leider den bürokratischen Prozess gar nicht beschreiben, weil ich das Vergnügen noch nicht hatte, das beantragen zu müssen.
Aber er ist komplex,
Aber er ist komplex und wir haben während das Projekt lief und eben so an der ein oder anderen Stelle darüber berichtet wurde,
lange Emails von Hausbesitzern bekommen, also von Privatpersonen,
jetzt weniger von Wohnungsbaugesellschaften, von Privatpersonen, die sagten, wir würden das auch so gerne machen
und wir sind so frustriert über die Bürokratie oder wir haben es gemacht und wir haben es bitterlich bereut,
bitte sorgt dafür, dass das auch an die Politik dringt unsere Bedenken, das kann einfach nicht sein.
Und das sind ja Sachen, die man dann vorher unterschätzt.
Also es ist wie gesagt auch der wohlmeinende Vermieter, der sagt, ich möchte die Energiewende unterstützen,
ich möchte da was tun und ich bin auch bereit, mich damit zu beschäftigen,
aber der dann irgendwann nur noch entnervt ist oder die.
Ich frage mich gerade, ob das nicht dann auch schon wieder ein interessanter Ansatz wäre für noch weitergehende interdisziplinäre Forschung
bis hin in die Politikwissenschaft hinein vielleicht,
um dann sozusagen auch diese Empfehlungskaskade bis eben auch in diesen bürokratischen Prozess zurückschwappen zu lassen, so zur Optimierung.
Also da ist überhaupt nichts gegen zu sagen, auf gar keinen Fall, das denke ich auch, das wäre sinnvoll.
Insofern könnten ja Folgeprojekte sich dann auch noch ganz anders gestalten.
/lacht/
Ich weiß nicht, ob man so breit denkt.
Ich meine, war ja am Anfang schon so ein bisschen meine Vermutung, ja, okay Wirtschaft, Recht und so passt ja alles ganz gut zusammen,
dass man so was halt auch breiter aufstellt.
Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht war das ja hier dann doch eine sehr scharfkantige Aufgabe,
in Zusammenarbeit eben mit der HTW, die dann eben auch konkret diesen ganzen solartechnischen konkreten technisch gesteuerten Bereich abdeckt,
eine gute Kooperation, aber grundsätzlich kann man sich ja auch solche Wissenschaftsprojekte vorstellen,
die dann eben noch größeres Empfehlungspaket am Ende ja auch liefern können sozusagen.
Auf jeden Fall und noch schöner wäre es, wenn es umgesetzt würde.
Ja. Haben wir denn jetzt schon alle Aspekte abgedeckt?
Also Anschlussprojekt hatten Sie ja schon erwähnt, soll kommen, aber ist jetzt sozusagen noch nicht beschlossene Sache.
Genau.
Ja, wir sind dabei, das zu beantragen.
Die Institution, die uns gefördert hat, haben wir noch gar nicht drüber geredet,
es gibt in Berlin ein Institut für angewandte Forschung, was eben solche Projekte mit finanziert,
die haben uns sehr geholfen, bei denen wollen wir wie gesagt das Folgeprojekt auf jeden Fall beantragen.
Und wie gesagt, wir fänden das toll, wenn wir das auch überprüfen können,
ob das, was wir rausgefunden haben, auch tatsächlich so funktioniert.
Und wir haben im Herbst letzten Jahres eine größere Online-Veranstaltung gehabt mit unseren Projektpartnern,
da war eine Reihe von Beteiligten drin, aber auch eine Reihe von Wohnungsbaugesellschaften,
die sich dazugeschaltet haben, also es war gar nicht so klein.
Und die haben einen halben Tag sehr intensiv sich die Ergebnisse angehört und darüber diskutiert,
wie sie das in ihren Projekten umsetzen können.
Also wir möchten das gewonnene Wissen, was wir jetzt haben, auch gerne an die Praxis weitergeben.
Und wie gesagt, haben angefangen, wollen das aber auch gerne weitermachen,
weil ansonsten, wenn man die Ergebnisse der Wissenschaft nicht verwendet,
dann braucht man sie auch nicht zu erheben.
Klar. Ich könnte mir vor allem auch vorstellen, dass man das auch noch ganz gut erweitern kann,
von Strom auf das ganz große Problem oder Heizens, was ja eigentlich noch ein sehr viel größerer zu hebender Stein ist an der Stelle.
Ist da schon mal drüber diskutiert worden, dass die HTW das Fass auch noch aufmacht?
Die HTW oder die HWR, meine?
Ja, wer auch immer sich drum kümmern möchte.
Aber da es ja, sagen wir mal, an der Stelle nur eine andere Technik ist, aber eine ähnliche Problematik.
Ja, ich würde die Frage fast an meinen nicht anwesenden Forschungspartner, Volker Quaschning, geben,
der sich sicherlich auch damit beschäftigt, aber aus Marketing-Sicht, wie gesagt,
wir sind jederzeit bereit, alle Gruppen zu untersuchen und zu evaluieren,
nur die Heizungsanlagen können wir nicht konzipieren.
Genau. Volker Quaschning, den wir hier auch in Forschergeist auch schon im Gespräch hatten vor vier Jahren,
Forschergeist Nummer 53, ich sehe gerade den Untertitel, der steinige Weg zu einer nachhaltigen Energieversorgung,
der ist nach wie vor steinig, aber auch solche Projekte helfen natürlich dabei,
hier das Pflaster ein bisschen erträglicher zu machen.
Ja, Frau Rumler, bleibt mir nur, vielen Dank zu sagen für das Gespräch.
Ja, ich bedanke mich.
Ja und natürlich auch, danke für das Zuhören hier bei Forschergeist, bald geht es wieder weiter.
Bis dahin sage ich, tschüss und bis bald.